حاله من الانتظار دامت لسنوات طويله
يعيشها مهاجرون شباب في مجمع رياضي في
مدينه المرسى التونسيه في دار الشباب
بالمرسى خلال الفتره بتاع خمسه شهور كان
نازل
الهلال الاحمر المهم همم بيجيبوا لنا ما
اكلوا وكده الى الخمسه شهور او سته شهور
وقصه منال وخلونا كده تبعنا يعني في ناس
يعني حتى
اغلبهم من بلاده لسوء الاحوال المعيشيه
فيها سعيا للوصول الى اوروبا احنا كنا همم
مشاكل وحرمنا من بلداننا في ليبيا الليبي
على اساس كان دوله
ومنظمات الدوليه وهما بينفسهم جابونا من
ليبيا الى المخيم شوشه جنوب تونسي
بعض منها
اوروبا وامريكا كندا والدول الغربيه واحنا
خلونا في مخيم الشوشه 6 سنين ونصف معاناه
بقدر احول لنا من المخيم شوشه الى مرسى
وادعوهم المادي والصحي سيء للغايه وقد
قذفناني منهم خلال فتره تفشي 19
لانه
قلت له في البلد الثالث